production begins at a foundry where
workers melt down bars of aluminum an
injection molding machine shoots the
molten aluminum into moulds in the shape
of players a robot removes the casting
from the injection machine the mold
yields four players each one sporting
the manufacturer's name on the front of
his jersey once ready the players move
to the foosball table factory where a
worker sprays on a base coat of white
paint once that dries workers continue
painting the players but now using an
airbrush after closing up the ends with
wood panels workers install wood support
bars which will reinforce the table and
after a goal direct the ball to the ball
returned tray
the table now goes to the paint shop
where workers either stain the wood or
leave it natural for this model they
also spray red stain into the recessed
stripes and logo all tables receive a
finishing coat of transparent varnish to
protect the wood they install the sloped
wall returned panel when a player scores
the ball rolls down the panel to an
aluminum ball return tray after sliding
the plywood table bottom into place
workers turn the table right-side up
mount the aluminum gollnitz and the
scoring units right behind them then
they lay the playing surface made of
green vinyl on pressed wood on top of
the wooden support bars wood trim around
the perimeter holds the surface in place
a worker mounts the players for each
line onto a hollow stainless steel rod
using a template to space them correctly
he bolts each player to the rod then
attaches a rubber bumper to the players
at each end to prevent them from
slamming against the side walls he
inserts a narrower stainless steel rod
into the hollow bar to make it
telescopic
[Music]
after preparing eight rods of players a
worker installs them in the table the
telescoping handle end of the rod has a
spring-loaded bearing that fits in a
hole in the table he secures it from the
outside after bolting the opposite end
workers protect the top edge of the
table with the plastic trim after
threading plastic handles to the
telescopic end of the rods and mounting
the tables on four sturdy solid wood
legs this foosball table is ready for
kickoff
[Music]